boa tarde meu nome é diego fortuné a eu
vim aqui hoje para contar a história de
um cara chamado eduardo eduardo é um
jovem brasileiro
ele é bonito era um cara atraente ele
tem várias mulheres
ele acaba de ser nomeado vice-presidente
da maior mineradora do brasil
com isso ele ganhou cerca de dois meses
e meio
sabe aquelas férias que a gente sempre
quis de dois meses e meio três meses
ele ganhou pra que ele pudesse descansar
pra assumir esse cargo
eduardo teve a idéia de aproveitar esses
dias pra mudar o mundo mas o que eduardo
faria para mudar o mundo com um cara que
tinha uma posição muito alta nem na
empresa com ele trabalhou muito tempo
ele era uma pessoa muito influente amigo
de muitos políticos e eu estava
acostumado com o muito luxo
ele decidiu pegar um avião sem roteiros
sem datas e foi procurar por moradores
de rua no mundo todo
eduardo seguiu para a cidade de paris
a primeira classe como estava acostumado
né
em paris ele conheceu um senhor chamado
jean jean ele estava estava no metrô em
paris onde ele morava
encostado ali né esquecido pela
sociedade francesa
eduardo quis conversar com ele e saber
um pouco mais sobre ele quando eduardo
foi conversar com ele é claro ele não
teve êxito
aquele morador de rua não se importou
nem um pouco com o eduardo é entrar
fazer perguntas e ele não respondia
eduardo passou a mão né enfrente os
olhos dele para ver se sentava com algum
problema visual qualquer coisa parecida
também não teve êxito e agora decidiu
então voltar para o hotel onde ele
estava o hotel de luxo como também
estava acostumado
no outro dia eduardo voltou no mesmo
lugar
aquele morador estava da mesma forma no
mesmo lugar com as mesmas roupas e com a
mesma cara apático ou seja ele não tinha
qualquer expressão
eduardo tentou falar com ele de novo não
conseguiu
eduardo tentou falar com ele no outro
dia também não conseguiu
até que na sua quarta tentativa ele
também não conseguiu então na sua última
tentativa ele falou vou tentar e não
conseguir voltar pro brasil vai esquecer
tudo isso de mudar o mundo vou ficar na
minha
não preciso disso aquele motu aquele
morador de rua ele tinha uma caixa com
ele uma caixa de papelão do seu lado
aparentemente ele proteger aquilo de
forma muito muito forte
eduardo se abaixou nessi para tentar
pegar aquela caixa
o morador de rua segurou no braço ele
falou você pode fazer o que quiser
comigo como sou como vocês estão
acostumados
só não leve tudo que eu tenho tudo ficou
muito curioso em saber o que tinha
dentro né
é claro que o morador não quis falar o
que tinha eduardo perguntou pra ele qual
era seu sonho
aquele morador respondeu pra ele que
moradores de rua não tem sonhos eduardo
claro o contrário disse não eu estou
aqui hoje para realizar o seu sonho pode
ser o que for
eu tenho dinheiro eu tenho tempo então é
só você escolher
ele escolheu ir a um espetáculo de balé
que naquela noite tinha inclusive esse
espetáculo em paris e era no olímpia
uma das das casas de show mais famosas
da europa
eduardo foi com aquele morador claro que
fez a barba dele levou de um banho e pra
poder entrar com ele nesse espetáculo o
que aconteceu lá foi realmente muito
incrível porque já abriu nessa sua caixa
pra mostrar o que tinha lá dentro para
eduardo tinha vários recortes de revista
jornal aparentemente era muito fã de uma
bailarina tinha toda a carreira daquela
barata bailarina dentro daquela caixa
o mais engraçado é que quando a diretora
daquele espetáculo subiu ao palco para
agradecer todo mundo que estava ali a
diretora era a mesma que que ele estava
dentro daquela caixa que ele colecionou
carreira daquela aquela moça por durante
mais de 30 anos
aquela moça era filha dele
ele não via há mais de 30 anos então o
sonho dele realmente não era ir a um
espetáculo de balé
o sonho dele era rever a filha isso é
uma história real é eduardo acho muito
legal falou poxa vida consigo realmente
mudar o mundo dessas pessoas
vou viajar o mundo todo agora eduardo
passou por cidades históricas cidades
maravilhosas quais são sonhos de todo
mundo
acho que muita gente que está aqui
também e ele seguiu pra eslováquia
provar que é um país muito bonito
ele foi nenhum monte chamado janela
covis pouca gente já foi
é um monte mais alto da eslováquia e lá
ele conheceu um senhor que se dizia
vidente que era vidente eduardo foi
legal é faça uma visão sobre mim ele
escreveu num papel passou por eduardo
medrado claro desdobrou e lá estava
escrito nunca deixe a sua família
agora acho engraçado perguntou para os
outros turistas que estavam ali mais
engraçado é que ele escrevia o mesmo
para todo mundo então ele realmente não
era um vidente
ele simplesmente escrever uma frase a
qual tinha um impacto muito forte pra
ele
um dia ele foi abandonado pela família e
ele tentava lutar mudando a forma de as
pessoas pensarem e mudar o mundo fazendo
com que ninguém ou seja nós não
abandonemos nossa família
eduardo continuou sua história continua
sua viagem
dessa vez ele foi para a suécia em
estocolmo
ele conheceu o morador no centro de
estocolmo que ele ficava com uma placa é
um papelão bem simples também
e tava escrito por favor me dê uma moeda
é normal de praxe eduardo passou deixou
uma moeda e foi almoçar quando ele
voltou lá estava escrito troca um
sorriso por uma moeda
eduardo foi perguntar para ele o porquê
daquilo ele usava as moedas que ele
ganhava pela manhã ele comprava sorriso
das pessoas na cidade durante a tarde o
dinheiro que ganhava e não comia não
fazia nada pra ele dizia que ele queria
mudar o mundo dizia que queria mudar a
cidade dele que as pessoas de lá não
costumavam sorrir nas ruas
eduardo ficou maravilhado com as
histórias claro mas ele percebeu que a
intenção dele de mudar o mundo não deu
certo porque esses moradores de rua
mudar o mundo dele eduardo voltou para o
brasil né
cheio de história cheio de idéias e e
claro que ele falando dessas histórias
na empresa onde ele trabalhava para os
amigos as pessoas realmente não
acreditava
achava que moradores de rua não podem
ter histórias muito legais e que talvez
não sejam tão interessantes
eduardo passou por cidades como milão
como passou por países como letônia
estônia lituânia países que as pessoas
nem imaginam que existam moradores de
rua mas existem eduardo viu que a idéia
de mudar o mundo não deu certo os
próprios moradores de rua
mudaram a história dele eduardo voltou
para o brasil sabendo da carência do
nosso país em falar outras línguas
acabou criando um projeto desse projeto
se chama eu poliglota esse projeto na
verdade leciona língua para quem não tem
condições
claro que eduardo conseguiu o êxito de
viajar o mundo e conhecer vários países
também por falar várias línguas eduardo
é um poliglota e então esse projeto
seleciona para quem não tem condições
eu me sinto muito muito feliz e
orgulhoso porque eu sou presidente desse
projeto na cidade de indaiatuba e é
claro que eduardo é um personagem que eu
mesmo criei que ele viaja o mundo conta
as histórias as quais eu pude presenciar
viajando o mundo
eu comecei a viajar com 19 anos parei
com em torno de 23 e coletei todas essas
histórias de moradores de rua pelo mundo
todo
o apresentei um trabalho um trabalho de
conclusão na faculdade criando um plano
econômico para moradores de rua
um professor de economia falou da 17
nossas fotos onde você tirou esses
relatos não pôde falar que eu viajei
durante mais ou menos quatro anos
conheci os seres mais inacreditáveis nas
histórias mais inacreditáveis que eu
pude conhecer
seria muita ganância minha guardar isso
tudo só pra mim o meu tcc né pôde
concluir a faculdade mas o meu de servir
um livro
esse livro conta não só a história de
eduardo um personagem que nós criamos
claro a gente tem muito em comum eu não
não sou vice-presidente da maior
mineradora do do país nem das américas
também não sou milionário qual ele
embora eu tenho muitas muitas piadas o
meu nome é diego fortuna mas está só no
nome e eduardo conta as histórias narra
as histórias neste livro sobre as
pessoas as quais moram nas ruas nos
países em todos mais de 40 países né do
do mundo todo
eduardo e eu nós temos um pensamento em
comum que as pessoas também
elas devem ter um mínimo de de
conhecimento o mínimo de de ajuda no
sentido de poder crescer de poder ter
acesso à cultura acesso acesso à
educação o projeto e poliglota traz um
pouco disso o projeto está na cidade de
indaiatuba há mais ou menos um mês e
meio
a gente já tem cerca de 15 voluntários
de pessoas que se inscreveram para dar
aulas também para quem não tem condições
e mais de mil curtidas no facebook foi
foi muito rápido também
o pessoal foi um passado a informação
para o outro foi bem legal e é um
projeto um projeto do bem
acho que é um pouco do que o eduardo
traço de lecionar línguas para as
pessoas para que elas também possam
realizar o sonho dela z e e viajar o
mundo talvez não têm melhores empregos
em ter melhores condições de trabalho a
gente sabe que no brasil apenas 5% da
população fala inglês e 5% estão
empregados espanhol não tem como nem
contar sendo talvez a segunda ou
terceira língua mais pedida pelas
empresas
esse é um projeto nosso é um projeto que
está na cidade e o que eu e eduardo a
gente tem mais em comum também é que as
pessoas devem ter
uma ajuda nesse sentido é uma forma de
trocar experiências trocar ajudas ea
gente pensa também que as pessoas
merecem de qualquer forma um lugar para
morar
bom gente obrigado boa tarde a todos